hier spricht die Moral was kann ich für Sie
tun bitte sie wollen dass ich es für einen
moralisch richtigen Befreiungskampf halte wenn
sie 1000 unschuldige Menschen ermorden also da
kann ich ihn nicht weiterhelfen unglaublich
hat alles die Moral auf seiner Seite haben
will Moral hallo ich soll bestätigen dass
es moralisch richtig sein kann Zivilisten
zu bombardieren um Terroristen auszuschalten
was sie meinen zwei Zivilisten pro Terrorist
sind eine einmalig niedrige Quote entschuldigung
aber das kann ich jetzt hier auf die Schnelle
nicht entscheiden Wahnsinn was hier gerade los
ist sie glauben gar nicht wegen was die Leute
mich hier anrufen Moral hallo Herr Scholz
ja bitte ja ich weiß sie g als klemtner der
Macht ich glaube trotzdem nicht dass es okay
ist ab jetzt für jeden Job die Anfahrt zu
berechnen Moral hallo Herr kubiki ich grüße sie ja
was haben sie für ein moralisches Dilemma ach gar
keins
klar ist klar sie wollten nur mal bisschen
quatschen so eine Kreuzfahrt kann schon mal
langweilig werden es gibt überhaupt nicht
gerade noch wollte keiner was won wir wissen
was musste ich mich in den letzten Jahren
beleidigen lassen hier als hypermoral als
moralistisch und moralinauer W zum regelrechten
Kampfbegriff zu meiner großen Überraschung von
Seiten der konservativen oh entschuldigung mein
neuer Premiumkunde da muss ich unbedingt dran
Wanger was kann ich diesmal für sie tun ja ja
ich finde es moralisch völlig in Ordnung dass sie
ihrem Bruder nichts zu Nikolaus geschenkt haben ja
schließlich haben sie mir schon genug in die Schuh
geschoben moralo wie kann ich Gewissen
erleichtern die katholische Kirche sind
be mir an der falschen Adresse ja ich verbinde
sie mal direkt mit der Staatsanwaltschaft und
Tschüss
okay klar genau das wollt ihr von mir
Absolution Mitleid Bestätigung ich bin
nicht euer Priester ich bin nicht eure
Therapeutin und ich bin auch nicht eure
Mutti Moral hallo Herr gottch ja wo
drückt nein ich bleibe dabei Frauen
ungefragt ans Knie zu fassen ist
auch nicht okay wenn keine Kameras
mehr mitlaufen was meinen Sie damit
man sieht mir die Moral gar nicht
an Moral hallo her Precht ja nein Sie müssen
mir nicht erklären was die Moral ist nein ich
halte sie nicht für den größten Philosophen
nein ich teile Ihre These nicht dass ich die
menschliche Moral aus der Katze entwickelt hat
Herr Precht es heißt kategorischer Imperativ und
nicht katagorischer Imperativ einfach mal
durchlesen bevor man was raushaut ja hab
recht man kann Bücher auch lesen nicht nur
schreiben nicht so schluss jetzt ist aber
mal ich weiß K alle wollen die Moral auf ihrer
Seite haben aber sein wir doch noch mal ehrlich
niemand will wirklich hören was ich zu sagen
habe die großen moralischen Fragen erfordern
für ihre Beantwortung nämlich Anstrengung in
Form von Mitgefühl und Empathie sich in die
Lage des anderen hineinzversetzen das kann
schon mal ordentlich zwicken so wird der Ruf
nach schnellen und schmerzfreien Antworten immer
lauter und am liebsten sind euch doch immer noch
die Antworten die euch eigentlich selbst schon
gegeben habt so ich ma für heute Feierabend ah
gut einer geht noch Moral hallo meine
Güte Herr Trump wie oft soll ich es noch
sagen ich bin für Moral zuständig und
nicht für oral ich bin zu alt für den
Scheiß so Herr utoff haben sie abonniert
Glocke gedrückt was sich eines von den
beiden Videos hier angeschaut hen sie
reicht mir vollkommen dass ich in den
meisten mitspielen muss her glauben Sie
dass es die richtige Art ist für uns
Werbung zu machen werde ich dafür bezahlt
nee was zum Henker mache ich dann hier er
ist sonst nicht so sie können sich ja in
der Zwischenzeit was ohne ihn anschauen